-Yeah, you know,
things are good.
I mean, we're back
in the studio.
We're live tonight,
which is cool,
but there's barely
anyone here.
It's a little weird.
-I know, man, it's like, we're
getting back to normal.
But at the same time,
not at all.
-Yeah, exactly.
But you know the one thing
I would love
more than anything?
Is to have a guest in person.
I miss talking to someone
in person.
-Yeah, man, I know
what you're saying.
I just miss being in the same
room with other people,
you know?
-Right?
-What's up, John?
-Hey, Jimmy, what's up?
[ Both screaming ]
[ Bouncy theme music playing ]
♪♪
-Live from Rockefeller Center
in the heart of New York City,
it's "The Tonight Show
Starring Jimmy Fallon."
Tonight, join Jimmy
and his guests
John Cena,
musical guest BTS,
and featuring the
Legendary Roots Crew.
♪♪
And now here's your host --
Jimmy Fallon.
♪♪
-Get it!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh!
Yes!
Hello!
Thank you very much.
Welcome to "The Tonight Show."
You guys,
we are live right now.
We are live from New York City!
[ Cheers and applause ]
And man,
what the hell was that...
debate?
Was that debate?
What did we -- I am so --
What was that?
I am so stressed right now.
I have a kink.
It just --
I felt like I just slept on
an air mattress.
Just one of those kinks
that just --
I got to get psyched.
We do have a great show tonight.
John Cena is here in the studio.
[ Cheers and applause ]
First live guest in the studio,
John Cena, we love him.
Also, we have music from BTS
every single...
[ Cheers and applause ]
...night this week,
we're having some performance
from BTS, it's gonna be good.
I'm actually pumped.
I am so amped right now,
President Trump demanded
I take a drug test.
That's how...
[ Laughter ]
Well, guys,
tonight in Cleveland,
it was the first
presidential debate
between President Trump
and Vice President Joe Biden.
And boy, wasn't that fun?
Seriously, did anyone take
anything away from tonight?
Was that helpful
to any American?
The only person enjoyed that
was Vladimir Putin
while he was stroking a cat.
"Yes. Yes, yes."
[ Laughs ]
Honestly, sitting through
that debate felt like
getting a COVID test
in both nostrils at once.
I was like...
[ Laughter ]
Seriously, after the debate,
I threw on "The Vow"
just to pick myself up.
[ Laughter ]
Things were tense tonight, man.
Usually when you see two guys
this age arguing,
it's about leaves blowing
on each other's lawn.
As expected, the debate was
full of hurtful insults,
constant fighting and
vicious personal attacks.
Or as Americans call it,
Thanksgiving.
[ Laughter ]
Before the debate, Chris Wallace
said that if he does
his job right,
it'll be like he's not there.
Well, mission accomplished.
[ Laughter ]
Things got really ugly.
After the debate was over,
Wallace said he wants to
moderate something a little
more civil
like a Real Housewives reunion
or a back alley knife fight.
Tonight's debate was presented
without commercials.
Yeah. The only interruptions
were Trump cutting off
Biden and Chris Wallace
every eight seconds.
[ Rapid stammering ]
"No, you're allowed...
[ Laughter ]
No, you said I have to do --
you have to do the --
I did what you said."
[ Laughter ]
Actually tonight's debate
made history.
It was the first time Americans
ever watched something on TV
and wished there were
commercials.
I need a break!
I break! Give me a gecko.
Give me something.
[ Laughter ]
Things got brutal fast.
Just to give you an idea,
this was one of
the lighter moments.
-All right, gentlemen --
-Which was heavily --
-Mr. President --
-You would have been
much later, Joe.
-Mr. President --
-Much later.
Mr. President --
-You're talking about
2 million people.
-Chris Wallace felt like
a kindergarten teacher
running a class on Zoom.
And the night went downhill
pretty quickly.
Biden was doing everything
he could to try to
get Trump to stop interrupting,
take a look at this.
-Donald, would you just
be quiet for a minute?
-And you don't know her --
-Will you shut up, man?
-Who was -- Listen --
-This is so unpresidential.
-He's gonna pack the --
-Will he just shush
for a minute?
-After that, Biden got
a standing ovation from Melania.
It's like...
"Finally!
Finally!
[ Applause ]
Some --"
At that point, I was just
waiting for a woman in a bikini
to walk out holding a sign
that said "Round 2."
[ Laughter ]
You know it was a rough debate
when the guy who told
the president to shut up was
seen as the classy candidate.
[ Laughter ]
Well, the first of the night's
six sections
was about the Supreme Court,
and it ended like this.
Watch this exchange.
-This is so unpresidential.
-He's gonna pack the Court.
-That was really a productive
segment, wasn't it?
[ Chuckling ]
Keep yapping, man.
[ Laughter ]
Sadly, looking back, that was
the most productive segment.
After that, the debate moved on
to the pandemic.
Then Biden tried to hit Trump
with a quick sound byte.
Watch this.
-When he was presented
with that number,
he said "It is what it is."
Well, it is what it is
because you are who you are.
-Ooh.
-Even Dr. Seuss was like, "Wait,
what are we talking about?"
[ Laughter ]
"It is what... we are --
is what you are?"
But Biden couldn't talk
about the pandemic
without bringing up
one of Trump's
most famous gaffes.
Check it out.
-This is the same man...
-It's all set up.
-...who told you by Easter,
this would be gone away.
By the warm weather,
it would be gone,
miraculously,
like a miracle.
By the way, maybe you could
inject some bleach in your arm
and that would take care of it.
This is the same man.
-That was said sarcastically.
You know that.
-Meanwhile, a guy injecting
bleach into his arm
was like, "Wait, what do you
mean sarcastically?"
[ Laughter ]
Trump is like,
"I don't inject bleach.
I wear a patch and slowly
absorb it all day."
[ Laughter ]
At the end of Trump's
presidency, he'll just be like,
"Come on, everything I said
was sarcastic.
Well, just...
[ Speaking indistinctly ]
No, you said that, I...
No, no, well, you said --
I said..."
Of course trump tried
to fight back.
He really took issue with Biden
using the word smart.
Watch this.
-Unless he gets a lot smarter
a lot quicker --
-Mr. President?
-Did you use
the word smart?
Don't use the word smart
with me.
[ Laughter ]
Yep. Trump accused Biden
of not being smart.
He was like, "I'm much smarter.
That's how is how I got
nominated for the
Taco Bell Peace Prize."
[ Laughter ]
And finally, Biden had
really had enough
and hit Trump with this insult.
-People out there need help.
-But why didn't you do it
over the last 25 years?
-Because you weren't
president --
-Why didn't you do it
over the last 25 years?
-Because you weren't president
screwing things up.
-You were a Senator and --
-You're the worst president
America has ever had.
Come on.
-Oof.
Trump was like,
"That's ridiculous.
Everyone knows I'm somewhere
between
George Washington
and Martin Sheen."
[ Laughter ]